in the early days of spring 2021 a few
strong anime had a monopoly on what they
thought
was just a relatively average season
they thought they had it set
at the top of the food chain until a
disturbance
and the balance of anime was felt across
the globe
gaekook felt it mother's basement felt
it hiding in public felt it
and of course the anime culture corner
certified biggest and
bestest anime channel on youtube felt it
as well
no one could have foreseen except for me
i'm sorry that odd taxi would jump up to
the number 32 spot on my anime list
uncontested after its final episode a
thrilling
mystery resolving and cliff-hanging
conclusion
that blew us out of the park was
odd taxi our underrated king of 2021
the anime youtube community certainly
thinks it is
but alas it is not
because not only is there a series even
more underrated than odd taxi from this
past
season but after its conclusion and
series finale it is rated
even better as well a show that i dug my
fingers into weeks ago
initially just in it for all of its time
travel galore
but afterwards realizing the absolute
magnificence and master class
that is link click edanghua
a chinese anime that has scored better
than jutsu tsukaisen
better than mob psycho season 2.
what is this mystery show why is it
rated so
highly what in it could possibly beat
out so many well-ranked anime
and as per request for my subscribers i
will assume that anyone who put elsa
congruent yes
and that even the people who said no
meant yes because i was going to do this
video regardless
i am back with another video on link
click
i did one approximately two weeks ago
before the series finished i came at it
with my thoughts
a summary of the plot and concept my
typical spiel really
and at the time i was still talking
about how i loved it
but that feeling has magnified
exponentially since the first season
ended
just like with odd taxi actually which
isn't surprising because both series
ended with huge cliffhangers
let me ask you a question how often do
you see end of season cliffhangers in
anime
code geass violet evergarden sure
there's there's a couple
but to have two in not just the same
season
but in the two best shows of said season
are you kidding me but the fact that it
has a cliffhanger is the only actual
spoiler i will leave you with here in
the intro of the video because there is
absolutely no way that i could afford to
worsen your experience of watching the
show yet
for those of you who have yet to get
around to it because it is just so
amazing but to be warned that there are
some minor details about the story and
characters
nothing specific about key plot points
like that but just enough to supplement
the length of this video
to fully encompass the greatness of the
show
and thus today is my fleshed out review
of all of link click the undisputed
best anime of 2021
now if you're this far without knowing
the concept of link click then let me
give you a quick
rundown in anime culture corners concise
compressed condensed and
every other sea letter word i could find
in the thesaurus summary
we follow two main characters who can
travel to the past through pictures
censor sorry if i mispronounced it goes
into the past through the bodies of the
photo takers
and lu guang guides him telepathically
in the present by telling him what
happens in that timeline and what he
must do to make sure nothing in the past
changes at all
what he must say how he must act and
people come to these two for various
reasons and odd jobs offering their old
photos
so the duo can find hidden information
from the past that can help in the
future because of course they can't
or rather won't change the actual past
finding a secret recipe from an old
friend
saying goodbye to a past lover you you
get the gist
it's an 11 episode time travel mystery
thriller back to your regularly
scheduled programming
[Music]
as i prefaced in my last video i love
time travel
i wouldn't say that i'm a time travel
know-it-all in the sense that i'm
nitpicky when it misses certain theory
or there's a small plot hole
but i will often notice them because
i've seen a lot
and it's just a difficult concept to
pull off in the first place
it's easy to make a mistake now most
anime take the simple approach of having
someone come from the future to change
the present
vivi did this orange did this the girl
who leapt through time most
time travel anime you can think of did
this
and it's because it's easier to pull off
you don't really have to worry about
paradoxes or nuances of time travel
because the main present cast of
characters are changing an
unknown future everyone wants to make a
better future so the show actually
encourages
making a new timeline changing the
course of their story
it's easier to integrate into an actual
story without having to explain much of
it scientifically
which is why i have even more respect
for link click
because it tackles the other more
difficult to traverse side of the coin
going from the present and changing the
past
something that was mastered by stein's
gate which set such a high standard for
how it should be done
changing the past inherently makes for a
complex story
and not only does link click go for this
more challenging approach but
it does it extremely tastefully and
truly expresses what i believe
are both the beauties and horrors of
time travel
chen sao shi and lu guang set up an
essential premise from the start of the
show
in fact the rules of time travel that
they self-impose
are the very first words of the entire
series
you get 12 hours chen must follow what
lu guang says
who knows the entire timeline and what
happens and change
nothing and lastly past or future
just let them be which comes to be the
focal point of the series
and the very human and emotionally
taxing challenge
of having an opportunity extended in
front of you
but having to force yourself not to take
it
and this is what i meant by the horrors
of time travel
everyone has regrets even if you don't
believe in regrets there are always
moments where you could have done
something better
and link click is all about that in the
very first episode we initially go into
this girl's photo simply to get secret
information from her boss
a relatively simple task only to be
unexpectedly thrown into a
grief-stricken story
of a broken and expectation-driven
family as well
chen in the girl's body wants to change
things
he raises questions like what will one
small change do i don't even know her
it won't even affect me which are all
reasonable to think
because at this point in the story the
very beginning
we as viewers also have no idea how
changing the past will affect the future
we agree with him in stein's gate we had
no idea about the real consequences of
messing with time
and how drastic they could be until that
fateful moment where it hits us like a
truck
or i guess hits us like a train
thank you thank you i'm here every week
[Applause]
and chen decides to make a change
yeah he he disobeyed rule number two
right off the bat in the show
but it was just a text to her mom so
small and heartwarming that even us as
viewers were willing to overlook it
because
hey what's it gonna do but we
immediately see the consequence at the
end of the episode
link click proves to us in just the
first 20 minutes
no time for slow burning no build up
that messing with time has real
consequences and truly sets us up for
the rest of the show
immediately reels us into this series
when faced with immense
unavoidable loss that you might have the
power to change
can you stop yourself from doing it even
if it's someone else's life
someone you don't know what likely won't
ever affect you personally ever
are you willing to hold yourself back
for the sake of
just being safe i mean you'll probably
change the timeline but
there's that lingering thought in your
mind what if your actions
don't there's also the aspect throughout
the show of
skepticism convincing yourself that
maybe doing one small thing
won't change anything significantly that
would all go right and well as you hope
it will
being in chen sausch's shoes having to
live through these people
is horrifying because there is not a
person in this world who wouldn't want
to act out in some of these moments
but you have to try to hold yourself
back
purposefully living through and
literally recreating your regrets
is there anything more horrifying than
that
excluding junjito of course because well
nothing's scarier than that
but not every story in link click is
stricken with sadness
many of which are actually very
beautiful and heartstring pulling tales
the beauty of time travel what i
mentioned earlier is in what we
typically fantasize it to be what it's
put on a pedestal as
what could have been and despite the
darker side the more realistic aspect of
time travel in the butterfly effect and
such consequences that the show dives
into
this brighter side does exist and
lingclick emphasizes that good
just as much as the bad shows like
orange almost focus entirely on the good
of time travel
of replacing the terrible future with a
better one and on the other hand
anime like stein's gate revolve entirely
around the consequences of it and
realizing that you never should have
messed with it to begin with
returning to the two different kinds of
time travel stories often when someone
comes from the future to the present
it focuses on the good of time travel
while present to the past focuses on the
bad
generally and even though breaking the
rules of time travel is link click's
central theme
it balances those losses with the
benefits of changing the past
census and lu guang have the chance to
reunited
separated families in the present and
finally bring together star-crossed
lovers who have never been able to be
with each other
all by simply gathering information from
the past and bringing it to the current
age their job does have its merits
even if they can't change anything in
the past they still have an
impact on people's lives that is
irreplaceable
but you're always thinking if they could
change the past if they were willing to
then that separated family never would
have been separated
those star-crossed lovers would have
always been together
the temptation of changing the past has
really never felt more real than it does
in link click and setting aside the
content and time travel of the show for
a moment disconnecting myself and
looking just at the production
pacing logistics it's all amazing
i said in my last video how the black
bars add to a cinematic feel visually
it's something anime doesn't often
do and the opening and ending songs are
just awesome and really bring the show
up a whole notch
but what i want to focus on here is the
pacing
the show is paced in a way that just
about every single episode ends in a
cliffhanger
it's not just the ending of the show
honestly i shouldn't have even been
surprised it ended with a cliffhanger
because it's such a common trope in this
anime that frankly
few to no other anime even pull off or
try to do
and the reason cliffhangers work so well
with link click specifically
is because it is a very episodic anime
the problem with episodic anime in my
eyes more often than not
is that the appeal of each episode
doesn't last
it is contained to just the 20 minute
duration of each episode of the series
which while it isn't necessarily a bad
thing on its own
becomes very difficult to binge through
it almost feels like watching multiple
mini movies and can get tiring
and cliffhangers the power of
cliffhangers
completely erases that every time you
finish an episode of link click
it's almost just slapping you in the
face and saying
wait there's more as someone who has
watched anime for a long time
my prime binging days are past me the
days or
just one day actually that i'm quite
proud of when i watched 46 episodes of
one piece in 24 hours
are long gone frankly and i can only
really binge series nowadays that i
really enjoy
or that are put together cohesively just
like link click
cliffhangers expand on the wow effect of
any show
the kind that leaves you jaw-dropped at
the end and wanting even more
and link click capitalizes on that and
completely turns it into one of the most
integral parts of this show's enjoyment
the bare bones of link click the concept
has been done before
the example that i immediately thought
of when i began the series was get
backers
a rather old anime around 2002 that also
had these two main characters
one being kind of the brains and the
other being the more charismatic and
headstrong one taking odd jobs for
people
also time travel isn't new nor are
murder mysteries
so it's not like link click at base
level really brings
anything inherently new to the table
it's simply the way it's delivered and
just how much
it delivers action suspense
thriller romance slice of life
hell even sports it is a show that is
not afraid to dive into the more complex
side of time travel
and the suspense of a good murder
mystery that isn't scared to add in a
bit of
everything and do it all extremely well
and i just absolutely love it especially
considering it
already faces an obstacle naturally as a
dongqua a chinese anime
the type of show that will always
experience less interest from audiences
or exposure
just because it's not japanese it's
incredibly rewarding to see such an
ambitious series take off in the way it
has
even if the actual audience that has
seen it yet is small
the rating truly reflects how good the
show is
and yes that is the end of my second
review on link click
if you guys have seen it since my first
video or just seen it in general
what do you think did you enjoy it and
if you haven't seen it yet but somehow
watched this entire video
i appreciate you but are you excited to
watch it now
leave a comment as always this has been
the anime culture corner i hope you
enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses